[音楽]
goo 2
はぁ
ああああああああ
ありがとうございます yeah
ジャピオンベル済分けられ場所ございません
a 一番多い容量データっていきいき paddy
いいえ買う気の難しいなじゃないですよねー
ここに振ったせずなるかこっちマーク x 雰囲気だったんですよね
ちょっと多分難しいなちょっとか難しいだあれちょっと株エール上達が上うまくキリリ
となるん
ねだいぶ杯分会に所属してまして私
ご存じないかと思うんですけど
今会え学生の終わりざぶめちゃめちゃう
北は広垣ザイル南大きな国際大学はねぇ
まあを多くてまっ証券がほぐれる
いわゆる落ちきるかちょっと違う落語研究会が漫才とか本の梅がある
言えなかったで言うと出身者あばれる君ということでレビュー思いますよねあの人も
大学を開いでやって語った
最近だとは笠田とジャイアントじゃあ8 e 1 by まぁを3回していた
とかサツマが rpg 3その使った
まぁちょっと知らないと思いますもしあのネタ番組とかあさっていただきていくんです
けど
ユーチューバーと水たまりもできます
僕同期なんですよ
ゴホン答えが強いに決まった
q 感じでレベルも高かった
規模だけ言うとこの枝の僕音楽伝えこれが400組で選挙
弱ぐらいチムポがいるという
からねなんかべんちゃん10いいね
早音さんにお願いしましょうはいです
a 棟まあいい背負った少年ですね可愛いね
どうですかねこれだけしましたからユーモアですけど僕は皆さんから見て
ふうに
[音楽]
別な人間に
いいんでしょう
新しいものを考えると思います
いうのは
直営参入ですよね
時代を作りしどうぞ
そういう意味ね新しい相手が発布するという意味であってその mitre
と視点で
宮里個別舞うかなぁという
まだー
僕は自分自身のことは
すごくグッズな人間なら会社します
ちょっと誤解があるかもしれないと
普通 in air
pal
ここじゃない
今日は使えます
山と岩です岡本端をさん松本人志さん
アッパー中湯芸者
すげーとに比べたら自分ずそんな姉あるっていう
ゆんです
あとは考え片手に複数があっ
ワンコインの500円のランチ方をやすいよ
思っ
創生日本人うち10日1年間は普通勝つよう虫
っていう感じの感覚的な考え方的に普通かな
思いません
皆さんも結構ねあるじゃないですか自分の子です就活したかった米さ
ね他人に負けないとこはどこですか言われたときに
いいや大学4年間ありやってだけど
あの人も馬だったしなぁ
みたいなんでしょうかは黒月ではない走る普通なんて思ったことあるか
61毒を持ったことあるいらっしゃいます
キャッシュしていただきありがとうございます
ちょうど推し好み記その2てあげていただきました
を使いますはい
今日僕はそんな皆さんをちょっと開け
特別な人間に特別な人に
力受けたいと思い
舞台に新しいことを考える人は得だと言いました
エターを作ることを笑いのネタを作ること
人は新しいものを考えていってしっかり
て音はそう
下手思いつく方法新しいものが発送方法ですねっ
これを教えることで皆さんにそっと誰でもどこ予算人間になっていただければ
具体的に言いましょうか
寝た方がいいと思うんですか
まず僕の中にも軽く説明します
ちょっとだねほんと二人でやるんですけど飛距離を保ってい
一方ねー
0みたいな感じ
人とここに携帯名が対してある感じだった
我々の会社の再申請 j子
従前の知力おかげで ss これは1年 wi-fi クルージュ
パスポートすべてを観覧した君たちの未来を展示していない
ありがとう質問があったか行かんしちゃっ
はいっ
確かに10問素晴らしい発明る踏み込むだと思いました
ただ市場ならずには少しコストが高くなるんじゃないでしょうか
出してそれ
続いてくれるに嘘数じゃ樹液を yg コン15終わったら
見せられたら日本語それ
企業名
写真夜中社長がを使えていません
ずっとのけど朝輝真の男イ
なのは私だけでないする思いません博したもの
機密文書のゆず味じゃないか
違うんですお前見ても観光来賠償人間なら山れたらお前だお前も逃走主お前も首で亜実
はあるがわかったらいいですね指図下
まんじゅうなのなー
あー20
ああああああ
tlr 200
ni
ええええええ
テリーはがあるんですよまあ月光剣と違う傘
これ実はある同じ動画を見ては方につい
なるだと思いますん
tv版と
ハイ心
2001年終わりのかもしれない
正解いきましょう世界こちら乃木坂ってどこ
9番ですね電話したこれはいえーいませんだ bipap 御坂工事中と思い
この先障害の人もいればも爺ですよね
西野なが使ってる人をしてございましたね写真も買いました
決勝連結婚することですねまあまあみてくださいをすべきな
それクラブサイト合っちゃってる昔あんなにいって方は
写真新婚でいます
この後7分に加速やめましょうと思いますねこんな話をしに来たんじゃないんですよ
乃木坂9分バンスメジャーせ
バナーマンさんという芸人になりました
40人ぐらい live at 降伏したり棄却したりいろいろするっていう番組です
じゃあこれを見てどうやっても行くの
4明かりは異例
犬年つアプリこれよりも知れもないなって思ってるのは僕なん
考えてもできないこれ
だからちょっ
で
乃木坂ってどこバラエティかもので佐久間で盗掘したいとロケしたいと
それを見てであおかしい
面白い編テレンスハプニング出てきたって思うこと結構あるんですよ
寝たままを見てたら思わないと思う
憲法 ioc の塩毛が生えたと言い方ですよ
な方が多いのでその人間ぽさそう思ってめちゃめちゃれる
で笑っちゃったんでしょうかあとを我々はいだけじゃなくてもう新しい多分
ありえねーっていう思ったところとかおお
集めねー
て集め分
じゃあこれすげー変革を持ったし
何コレ終わりにできないかなぁ
全部考えて言ってあこれイケこうって思ったものがあるメタになりますこれだねた顔も
いく方法です
これがあると聞いたのであとみなさんこれちょっと姉たら作れるも退く際に期にやや
近づいたはずです
ss なくなりましょうこれネタないんじゃなくても皆さんのジャンルでも考え方が家
だったらいけるはずです
今言いました違和感特殊て何のこれ新しい
てもとにかく遊んだりくっついてるに至ると
集める
おっ少しほんとも集めて他のジャンクなったものを自分のジャンルに持ってきて
ください
これをやることで物事新しい
ここを思いつくまあ現実減の新しい見せられ
ことができると思います
新しい見せるちょっといいかだけだから1会
はい仮に方しますけどまぁ結局その
やつだから
音楽再生プレーヤーにカメラが搭載されから新しいなくなりました
あると同じところも族カメラってあるものなんですか
これがあっていますみたいなことを
でいい
あ
チェッカー33という人はわずかです終わりとじゃないですねモーション
すごく好きな言葉で
1ビルの映画ほどう
家流能楽を着てい
19の芝居を
一流の方載っ
そしてそれから自分の世界を作るということを
まさにその通りつなります
そういったことを実践していただければ新しいと思う
どうでしょうちょっとずつ皆さんとクェーサー禁煙
新しいものを作る気していけません
西へ
good 優男餌に良い近づけでご分析してもらいたいと思う
ています
じゃなきゃ一番大事じゃなく新しいを考える
ないわーんと出国して
好きでほか74者に持ってくる
まあ大事ですねこれにままです
一番ダメなのは何か
いわば監督したように気づくことですじゃない
いわば1地点にキュッとかなぁ
はいあーいや間の確執がないと言い方をさが相撲力が大事なんです
探さないと君ないです
はい行きますね最後に近づけ方になりますよ
いわばンっていうのは
つまり普段起こらないことです
札起こらない元っていうのはつまり
特別なことです
特別なことを探せる能力が気づく労力が一番大事だ
じゃあ特別なことを探せる能力なるんだ
特別がないか分かる
つまり
特別じゃないことが何かということに気づけるん
特別じゃない事を知ってることこれが大事です
時計ことはつまりどういうことなのか
普通であることが一番大事なんだよん
普通なという感覚を持ってる人間が
開くらしいものを発送できるんだと思っています
決まりました禁断エリアした家が一番ある空間ですね
ふうに補修さん
はーい
上がってくれません
今日もが何でここですねもう1年僕が普通だと思って
だからここ
特別なも岩からに続いて
温浴
ちゃんと見られたし結局君にさせていただかせていただいています
始め
皆さんの自分のことを普通になっています
それはもう皆さんはいい
特別な人になれるということを自分自身で右を上げて証明してくれん
そういうばいい
新しいことを作る人間が特別など言われます
地雷を作ります
そういう意味でペット妊活人間は特別なのかもしれません
ひょっとしたら次に zepp に立つのは
お客様から誰かなかもしれないと僕は思ってます
それを確約したありがとうございました
はぁ
ta ある